in this video we're going to take a look
at every Spider-Man actor and voice
actor from 1970 all the way to 2024 so
here are 10 different Spider-Man actors
as seen in the movies and video games
the first live-action Spider-Man movie
was actually a made for television film
that aired on CBS in 1977 it was based
on the Spider-Man TV series that ran
from 1977 to 1979 starring Nicholas
Hammond as Peter Parker Hammond was a
27-year-old actor who had previously
appeared in The Sound of Music as
Friedrich Von trap he wore a spandex
suit with a plastic mask and we shooters
that looked kind of like bracelets the
movie was a pilot for the TV series and
it introduced the characters of J Jonah
Jameson ant May and Robbie Robertson the
plot involved Spider-Man trying to stop
a nuclear bomb from exploding in New
York City the movie was a modest success
and it spawned two sequels that were
edited from episodes of the TV series
Spider-Man Strikes Back In 1978 and
Spider-Man the dragons challenge in 1979
the movies weren't released theatrically
in the United States but they were shown
in some foreign countries like Japan and
France the 1970s Spider-Man movies are
mostly remembered for their cheesy
special effects lowbudget production
values and campy tone they aren't
considered part of the official
Spider-Man Cannon but they have a cult
following among many fans in 1978 we got
a Japanese version of Spider-Man which
was very different from the original
comic book character this Spider-Man was
named tuya Yamashiro and he was a
motorcycle racer who gained spider
powers from an alien named Gia he also
had a giant robot called leopardon which
he used to fight monsters and villains
the Japanese Spider-Man was part of a
liveaction TV series that ran for 41
episodes and it also had a theatrical
spin-off movie that was released in 1978
the plot involved Spider-Man fighting
the Iron Cross Army a terrorist
organization led by Professor Monster
the movie was a hit in Japan and it
influenced the creation of other
Japanese superhero shows like super
centai and common rider the Japanese
Spider-Man movie was never released in
the United States but it was later made
available for streaming on Marvel's
official website in 2009 the movie is
known for its bizarre and creative
interpretation of Spider-Man and it has
a loyal fan base among some Marvel
enthusiasts in 2002 spider Spider-Man
finally made his big screen debut in a
Blockbuster movie directed by Sam Ry and
starring Toby Maguire as Peter Parker he
wore a latex suit with a rubber mask and
had organic web shooters in his wrists
the movie was based on the original
comic book origin story of Spider-Man
and it introduced the characters of Mary
Jane Watson Harry Osborne Uncle Ben and
Aunt May the movie was a huge success
and it received critical Acclaim for its
faithful adaptation thrilling action and
emotional depth it also spawned two
sequels Spider-Man 2 in 2004 and
Spider-Man 3 in 2007 these Movies
featured villains like Dr Octopus
Sandman Venom and the new Goblin the toy
Maguire Spider-Man movies are widely
regarded as some of the best superhero
movies ever made and they have a massive
fan base around the world in 2012 Sony
rebooted the Spider-Man franchise with a
new movie called The Amazing Spider-Man
directed by Mark Webb and starring
Andrew Garfield as Peter Parker the plot
involved Spider-Man trying to stop the
lizard who was played by ree eens the
movie was a commercial success but it
received mixed reviews from critics and
fans some praised its realist IC and
gritty approach while others criticized
its lack of originality and charm it
also had a sequel The Amazing Spider-Man
2 in 2014 this movie featured villains
like Electro Rhino and the Green Goblin
the Andrew Garfield Spider-Man movies
are generally seen as inferior to the
toy Maguire ones and they have a
somewhat divided fan base in 2016
Spider-Man joined the Marvel Cinematic
Universe a shared Universe of superhero
movies produced by Marvel Studios and
Disney Spider-Man was played by Tom
Holland a 19-year-old actor who had
previously appeared in movies like The
Impossible in the heart of the see and
How I Live Now he wore a high-tech suit
with a mechanical mask and web shooters
that were given to him by Iron Man Who
was played by Robert Downey Jr
Spider-Man made his debut in Captain
America Civil War where he fought
alongside Iron Man against Captain
America and his allies he then had his
own Solo movie Spider-Man homcoming in
2017 followed by Spider-Man far from
home and Spider-Man no way home he also
appeared in Avengers Infinity war and
endgame where he fought against Thanos
and his army the Tom Halland Spider-Man
movies are popular for their fun and
fresh take on Spider-Man their
integration with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and their charismatic and
Charming lead actor they're considered
part of the official Spider-Man Cannon
and they've been connected to other
Spider-Man movies through the concept of
the Multiverse in 2018 Sony released an
animated movie called Spider-Man into
the spider-verse directed by Bob petti
Peter Ramsay and Rodney Rothman and
starring Shmi Moore as Miles Morales
Moore was a 23-year-old actor who had
previously appeared in movies like dope
the get down and Cutthroat City he
voiced a teenage Spider-Man who had a
black and red suit and web shooters that
he inherited from another Spider-Man the
movie was based on the comic book
storyline of the same name and it
introduced the concept of the
spiderverse a Multiverse of different
spider people the plot involved Miles
Morales teaming up with other spider
people such as Peter Parker Gwen Stacy
Spider-Man Noir spiderham and Penny
Parker to stop the Kingpin the movie was
a critical and Commercial hit and it won
the Academy Award for best animated
feature it also had a sequel Spider-Man
across the spiderverse in 2023 this
movie featured more spider people such
as Spider-Man 2099 Spiderwoman and
spider Punk the shamik Moore Spider-Man
movies are praised for their Innovative
and colorful animation their diverse
dynamic characters and their humorous
and heartfelt tone in 2018 Sony released
a video game called Marvel Spider-Man
developed by insomnia games and
published by Sony interactive
entertainment for the PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation 5 consoles the game featured
Yuri lenthal as Peter Parker a
23-year-old superhero who had been
Spider-Man for 8 years he wore a classic
red and blue suit with a white spider
emblem and web shooters that he designed
himself the game was was an original
story that was not based on any previous
comic book or movie adaptation and it
introduced the characters of Miles
Morales Otto Octavius Martin Lee and
silver Sable the plot involved
Spider-Man trying to stop the Sinister 6
a group of super villains led by Dr
Octopus the game was a critical and
Commercial Success and it won several
awards for its gameplay Graphics story
and voice acting it also spawned two
video game sequels Spider-Man Miles
Morales and Spider-Man 2 the Spider-Man
PlayStation games are considered to have
some of the best storytelling in the
Spider-Man franchise and are praised for
their immersive and realistic depiction
of Spider-Man and for their spectacular
combat Spider-Man has appeared in many
other video games over the years and
he's been voiced by many different voice
actors some of the most notable ones are
Josh Keaton who voiced Spider-Man in
several video games such as Spider-Man
Web of Shadows in 2008 Spider-Man
Shattered Dimensions in 2010 Spider-Man
Edge of Time in 2011 and Marvel versus
Capcom 3 in 2011 he also voiced
Spider-Man in the animated TV series The
Spectacular Spider-Man from 2008 to 2009
he's known for his witty and energetic
performance and he's one of the fan
favorite Spider-Man voice actors there
was also Christopher Daniel Barnes who
voiced Spider-Man in several other video
games such as Spider-Man the Animated
Series in 1995 Spider-Man The Sinister 6
in 1996 Spider-Man the game in 2000 and
Spider-Man friender foe in 2007 he also
voiced Spider-Man in the animated TV
series Spider-Man from 1994 to 1998
there's also Neil Patrick Harris who
voiced Spider-Man in the animated TV
series Spider-Man the new animated
series from 2003 to 2004 he's known for
his charismatic and humorous performance
and he's one of the most popular
Spider-Man voice actors lastly there's
Drake Bell who voiced Spider-Man in
several more video games such as Marvel
Superhero Squad Online in 2011 Marvel
Avengers battle for Earth in 2012 Disney
Infinity Marvel superheroes in 2014 and
Marvel pinball in 2015 he also voiced
Spider-Man in the animated TV series
Ultimate Spider-Man from 2012 to 2017
he's known for his youthful and
enthusiastic performance and he's one of
the most prolific Spider-Man voice
actors ever which Spider-Man actor is
your favorite drop your thoughts in the
comments below also don't forget to
subscribe and if you like the video
check out the other one on your screen
too